this looks very Elwood it's so well I
might need to borrow it if we make
legally one three I'll give you I'm
gonna talk about it you know what I'm
just skipping to behind the scenes we're
on the subject let's do it
[Applause]
thank you so much all right rom-com
royalty for Christmases this is a fly on
the wall a tidbit moment first thing
that comes to mind juicy detail
something we would never know otherwise
go okay first of all every almost every
scene is improvised Vince Vaughn is one
of the funniest people I've ever met my
entire life literally trying to hold my
stomach there's a scene where I'm
holding a baby and it spits up on me and
y'all you if you watch it again you have
to see how fast they have to cut away
from me because I was dying laughing
fake baby it was like a tube inside of a
shooting pancake batter anyway
[Applause]
that's like in our jobs when I always
say you never know where the day is
going to take you yeah
um but so he's that funny he is so funny
because I don't know him very well I've
never gotten to work with him yeah and
the way I see him like when I watch him
it feels so natural and off the cuff
like he's riffing but I don't know if
that's the case it is completely making
it up on the day he's completely making
it up and so you have to roll with it
you have to keep a straight face too or
add on which was I learned so much on
that movie about improv and being quick
on your feet I mean you're so vet you
know that but I had never had to do that
and that was good for me because it you
know it's important to level up in your
work keep your toes boy he made me level
up I was like oh I gotta keep having
this one oh that's so hot I love that
that's good okay
um Legally Blonde of which I'm dressed
my own to the great do you see I mean
look at me I am in honor of Elwood snake
Okay amazing yeah I want to tell you
something about the courtroom scene was
inspired by my cousin Vinnie have you
ever seen my cousin Vinnie okay Marissa
Tomei in that movie she won an Oscar for
it that's right she came in at the very
end and testified with this very
technical jargon about a car or a
carburetor and I was like I said to the
writers I want to have a moment like
that where I say something very specific
about only Elwoods would know it and
it's about a perm oh I remember and it
was inspired by Marissa that you would
never get in the shower after a purse
yes Sweet Home Alabama sweetness
out I remember that scene that we shot
in the rain and and I'm in the um
wedding dress I run away from my wedding
and I run to see Josh Lucas on the beach
and it was pouring down rain but I
remember thinking this is such a crazy
amazing moment I'm gonna remember this
forever and I still have the wedding
dress
true I heard this weird rumor but I have
no idea it's true is the scene in
Tiffany's inspired by like a real life
story I don't no but we really were in
Tiffany's and they really shut down all
of Tiffany's turned off all the lights
and then turned them on and all the
Rings were there and all the people who
worked there it was really magical well
it was Andy Tennant I've always who
directed your movie ever after I did
yeah
right he's so brilliant and so he did
Ever After pitch pitch and he did Sweet
Home Alabama Cruel Intentions
look at Sarah look at your baby oh my
gosh you know what's so
just love that movie too because I love
that that dichotomy between the two of
us that one of us presents is sort of
this good virginal perfect girl but
she's really as masterminding as as
Sarah's character and it was just that
was such a fun movie to make I remember
driving in a vintage Jaguar Down The
Long Island freeway going I hope I don't
crash I will never forget and I was
wearing sunglasses those old cars are
hard to drive they are really hard to
drive it's a good thing my brother
taught me to drive a stick when I was
little I learned how to Renault the car
you got to learn you have to know and by
the way if you want your kids to text
less make them drive us oh that's a good
point
it's going to be my new parenting hack
that's actually yeah right yes
also I commend your performance on this
so much because I feel like I watch your
character truly grow up yeah over the
course of the movie which is like a very
methodical but yet executed very
naturally yeah the Innocence into the
understanding and the playing the game
and then winning it's a real Evolution
yeah and it's also about loss of
Innocence too I think that always
resonates with people you know how do
you feel like and ah gosh I love Sarah
so much it's funny because we have a mom
story together too we had kids the same
age all three of our kids all of
Tennessee and her son Rocky are all the
same age our kids are born on the same
yeah by the way yeah on the same day and
we were at my wedding pregnant with our
two bellies
and then we gave birth on the same day
it was really fun okay
the one I was bragging about earlier
your Academy award-winning performance
Walk the Line
okay
um I worked so hard on this show and
Joaquin just could not have been more
magical he
he became Johnny Cash right in front of
us and and it was it was really magical
and it was meaningful I felt like the
spirit of June Carter the whole time I
felt Johnny was watching us I was about
like it's also I'm from Nashville
Tennessee so country music has been part
of my upbringing so it was really a love
letter to country music and where I came
from okay the morning show
foreign
look at our faces
we're both like what
um I mean just getting every day to work
with her and get to do these fun scenes
we were just talking about it the other
day I just wrapped on Saturday we
wrapped season three yes
definitely coming out this year this
year this year all right big little lies
all right
season two when you bring in Meryl
Streep talk about bringing that woman
into this game with you guys that was
another gift she called and said I think
I want to be on the show and we're like
[Music]
so where are you when that call comes in
so
Meryl Streep on line one Meryl Streep
she called Nicole Kidman because they're
very close they had done a lot of shows
together of course they are and so
Nicole calls me she goes
I'm gonna do my bad Australia she's like
um race now called and she wants to be
in the in the big little lies too and I
was like
what
what yes okay really quickly friends I
love you as Rachel's sister and
it's where the morning show connection
started
honestly she's such an icon they were
all icons set like it's incredible
Central Perk was amazing I got to sit at
the couch at Central Park can I tell you
my favorite line from Friendship yeah
that I actually got to say the writers
were so brilliant so she says look you
can have any guy you want but you can't
have Ross and I go can't have can't have
the only thing I can't have is dairy
[Applause]
it's so funny I love it
[Music]